we started a business in the middle of a
pandemic y'all
however sold a hell of a lot of shoes
and we knew it was going to happen
because we understood that there was a
need for this type of thing because we
needed it also
the sneaker resale market is booming
totaling an estimated two billion
dollars in north america alone
as shoe manufacturers focus on driving
sales away from brick and mortar stores
and towards mobile apps and websites
sneaker resellers
are reaping the benefits
the name of our business is another lane
we are the premier destination for dope
kicks
so not only do you have a marketplace
you can sell with
no seller fees and then on top of that
you get communication so you can
you know ask someone hey does the shoe
fit small can i get 50
off those types of things encouraging
community also you have a unique url to
your store
you want to be in the background
[Music]
when i think about sneakers and my
infatuation with them
i don't wear it like a badge of honor
it's kind of embarrassing
and so when i wanted to ask her out i
mentioned it very like
ever so slightly and adina kind of just
shrugged it off like
everybody's into sneakers so you're no
different than anybody else
until the first time i visited his house
i was like oh
this is different his entire bedroom
looks like the back room of foot locker
yeah so this is my favorite place in the
world because this is where i house
my personal collection this is a air
jordan 2009
prototype sample inspired by april
holmes
she is a gold medalist paralympian
[Music]
lebron 4 all-star player edition that he
wore in the all-star game
and last jordan brand just came out with
the jordan 11 adapt
this is nike's first auto lacing
air jordan 11. every shoe that adena
likes is either from the 70s or the 80s
me i like the new stuff anything new and
different that's what i want to try out
and i want to be the first to tell you
if it sucks
or if it's awesome
[Music]
the challenges of being business
partners and being married
especially in a pandemic your home is
your office your office is your home
i was saying some days i'm the janitor
you know and then other days i'm the cfo
[Music]
chad has seen you know returns of a
hundred to a thousand percent
on some shoes the stewie griffin is
actually the highest dollar amount for
one
pair of sneakers so the shoe was never
released to the public about two years
ago i sold that shoe
for nine thousand dollars just to see
people old goal at a shoe that they've
only heard of
and to see people's jaws just drop like
isn't that what we do with art all the
time
is we go to a museum we look at it we
love it we talk about it because it
makes us feel things
i mean that's what my personal
collection is it's my museum in my house
the sneaker boom has also created
opportunities for a new generation of
speculator
the potential to get rich quickly in an
informal setting with little oversight
drew a new breed of online gen z trader
exchanges like stockx they commodify
this hobby that we love the personal
communication was taken out
and community was taken away i don't
think that the
audience has changed i think that it has
grown and so it has expanded to include
the white kid from the suburb that is
influenced by
the black culture i'm so happy to see
the world
enjoy sneakers and see what's so dope
about them
but it can sometimes feel like a
gentrification you want it to still have
some of the flavor
the people that made it what it is
that's another reason why
we were so happy to create another lane
is that we didn't see anybody that
looked like
us at the top of these sneaker companies
and so we wanted to
assign that face and put us back into
space and places
[Music]
in my younger years it was completely
and totally for the
the passion and the art of it i had all
these sneakers because i love them i
love to wear them i love to play in them
i love to show them off
also it's it's really about the personal
connections that you make along the way
there are people that chad waited in
line with with sneakers and
now they're really close friends and
he's been in their wedding
that is what a community gives you
it's expanded my life like i'm from
brooklyn my network though has taken me
all over the world because of my life
for sneakers
i know what it felt like when i got that
pair of shoes from my personal
collection
so to be able to share something like
that and that same feeling
be transferred that's the best part of
it
hey thanks so much for watching for more
videos like this you can train bloomberg
quick take for free 24 7 in any of the
places below
get live news coverage interviews deep
dives
shows and documentaries on the stories
you care about most
and be sure to follow or subscribe to us
on twitter youtube instagram and
facebook